[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 le journal ravi de vous
retrouver voici les titres de ce jeudi
22 juin 2010 est présenté un bilan de mi
mandat pour les équipes municipales
c'est revenir sur les engagements de
campagne constaté la réalisation totale
ou partielle des promesses faites avant
l'élection programmée pour définir les
actions à venir à bois d'arcy philippe
benassaya et son équipe municipale ont
décidé d'aller rencontrer les habitants
dans les quartiers de la commune le
conseil des seniors est une instance de
concertation composé de représentants de
tous les quartiers et des associations
il permet à la municipalité de mieux
répondre aux attentes spécifiques des
seniors je conseille élabore des
propositions concrètes soumise à la
municipalité
la première séance d'installation à
maurepas et lieu ce vendredi 16 de juin
présentation du premier autocar
électrique de tourisme livrer à une
compagnie d'autocars en europe à bitche
le véhicule de toutes dernières
technologies et tout électrique avec
zéro émission de co2 il a également une
autonomie de 200 km idéal pour les
excursions et les découvertes de sites
touristiques et nous commençons ce
journal par des images du salon du
bourget le 52e salon international de
l'aéronautique et de l'espace du bourget
s'est ouvert lundi pour les
professionnels et ouvrira ses portes au
grand public vendredi samedi et dimanche
de nombreuses entreprises du département
et de l'agglomération sont présentes
comme l'aéro club de saint cyr l'école
avec des démonstrations de voltige
aérienne
je vous propose d'écouter régis
alajouanine il est président fondateur
de lava à saint-cyr-l'ecole le cursus
normal ce sont des pilotes qui a appris
à piloter et au bout d'une fine et leur
brevet ils font après un an ou deux de
vol jeudi
rey à plat et bien souvent ils viennent
ils veulent continuer leur progression
lors la maniabilité et viennent nous
voir parce qu'ils ont plaisir de l'air
et un voltige aérienne on bénéficie
vraiment de l' avantage de pouvoir
pratiquer les trois dimensions
réellement alors que quand on vole on va
décoller faire un pallier pendant une
heure décente qui était alors que là
pendant 20 minutes ou une demi heure on
est dans tous les coins du boxeur et
trois dimensions l'heure est au bilan de
mi-mandat pour les mères à bois d'arcy
philippe benassaya et son équipe
municipale ont décidé d'aller rencontrer
les habitants dans les quartiers de la
commune
une démarche de concertation lancée le
10 juin dernier reportage de nicolas
dedans brille déjà trois en trois ans à
la tête de la ville de bois d'arcy pour
philippe benassaya
le maire fait un premier bilan de son
expérience il parcourt la ville avec un
bus électrique pour expliquer les
politiques qu'il a menées entre 2014 et
un moment aussi de concertation et de
critiques avec les arcisien ya pas eu
d'augmentation d'impôts alors qu'il
n'avait eu dans les années précédentes
c'était assez élevé
donc là ça s'est stabilisé donc c'est
déjà une bonne chose il ya un gros
problème et circulation dans le quartier
sur la départementale 127 qui passe donc
à côté de la mairie
donc tous les soirs c'est vraiment
saturé et on a du mal à rentrer chez
nous ou écouter j'en suis pas mécontent
monsieur benassaya de fait de son mieux
on manque de crèches il ya une micro
crèche qui
je pense qu'il ya un projet d'ouverture
d'une microcrèche prochainement
mais ça ne suffira pas parce que sachant
que le temps d'attentes en fait elle est
en moyenne de 2 ans à l'inscription
je pense que la priorité doit être
doit être fixée sur ce volet la création
de la police municipale construction du
gymnase colette besson ou encore la
rénovation du cosec plusieurs promesses
réalisé en 3 ans non sans difficulté
maintenant ce qui est très très
difficile
c'est la lenteur administrative on va
dire la lenteur pour monter un projet
c'est toujours très très très long il ya
énormément d accueil pour monter le
moindre projet et ça c'est ça c'est
compliqué et ça c'est pénible pour te
dire dernière étape pour ce minibus
électrique ce samedi 27 juin au quartier
de la trembler le matin et quartier
saint-jean l'après midi la première
séance d'installation du conseil des
aînés s'est tenue vendredi 16 juin une
instance pour consulter les personnes
âgées de maurepas des seniors qui
représentent 4 1300 habitants sur la
commune
le but améliorer leur cadre de vie ex
cadre de vie explication nicolas dombes
et le suffrage par le sort et de la
nature de la démocratie écrivait
montesquieu dans l'esprit des lois au
18e
trois siècles plus tard le maire de
maurepas grégory gars ici a choisi le
tirage au sort pour former son conseil
des aînés une institution participatif
pour les morts patients de plus de 62
ans
je veux aussi continuer de travailler
ses liens forts que j'avais clément
patients en les associant évidemment aux
décisions et en recueillant aussi leur
avis évidemment les élus reste
décisionnaire je suis le représentant
donc j'ai dû continuer de décider mais
je construis avec les moyens et c'est
pour ça que je multiplie les instances
participatives composé de 46 membres 30
titulaire et 16 suppléant le conseil des
aînés est chargé d'éclairer le ccas
trois commissions thématiques cadre de
vie prévention et lien social des sujets
de réflexion allant de la mobilité à la
santé en passant par le maintien à
domicile ou les loisirs c'est pour
pouvoir participer un petit peu
l'amélioration du cadre de vie de
de ma ville les personnes âgées il ya
aussi de plus en plus de personnes
handicapées donc a besoin aussi de
prévoir beaucoup d'activités non
seulement des activités mais des prises
en charge au niveau des aides à domicile
au niveau des droits de connaître les
droits
je me suis dit peut-être que au niveau
de la mairie il y aurait peut-être la
possibilité de faire quelque chose par
rapport aux personnes qui sont à
mobilité réduite ou handicapées comme
moi qui reste domicile prochain rendez
vous la commission lien social prévu fin
juin début juillet à l'ordre du jour
l'élection des coordinateurs de la
commission et les discussions sur le
voyage seniors 2018 une petite
révolution dans le monde du transport la
société big raynaud premier loueur de
véhicules de transport de voyageurs
élargit son offre et propose désormais
un autocar 100% électrique il s'agit du
premier autocar de tourisme électrique
d'europe
présentation de ce nouveau modèle avec
camille lambert et mélinda corriera
cinquante et une place sièges
inclinables prise usb et climatisation
tout le confort d'un autocar classique à
un détail près
il a par là j'ai mon temps
[Musique]
si vous avez l'habitude des voyages en
car vous aurez remarqué que celui ci est
particulièrement silencieux 100%
électrique
ce modèle du constructeur be wild y ait
zéro émission de co2 et 0 knox sources
de pollution un véhicule écologique avec
une conduite souple
si je devais refaire un city tour je le
ferais probablement avec celui ci on
ressent beaucoup moins la fatigue
le fait qu'ils soient automatiques qui
est déjà le fait qu'il soit souple
silencieux
tous les pollutions sonores déjà pour le
conducteur c'est très important parce
que c'est source de fatigue
cet autocar a rejoint l'écurie de la
société be green loueur de véhicules de
transport de voyageurs
grâce à son autonomie de 200 km il sera
utilisé pour des excursions ou des
découvertes de sites touristiques
il s'agit du premier de ce type en
europe be green se veut un modèle de
transition énergétique
on se doit de de la mettre en oeuvre
puisque ces produits existent
aujourd'hui
donc on doit faire partie des exemples
en matière de transport collectif propre
à partir du moment où les constructeurs
nous présente ces nouveaux véhicules et
notamment celui-ci qui est vraiment dans
la lignée le véhicule du futur qui en
annonce d'autres puisque là on est dans
l'antichambre avec l'électrique
l'antichambre de transport à hydrogène
qui existe déjà
fondée en 2010 be green propose
aujourd'hui 33 véhicules de transport en
commun électrique
on voit maintenant parler de sport et
plus précisément de running dans cette
édition malgré les fortes températures
de ces derniers jours la cour royale
était organisée ce dimanche pour la
sixième année consécutive dans les
allées du château de versailles
comme chaque année la compétition a fait
le plein ils étaient plus de 10000 à
prendre le départ de l'épreuve les
détails avec michael et demi d'euros et
hip hop steinberg et on aborde comme
entretient il avec le sourire et le
soleil de positions les plus suivis du
département la course royal est une
nouvelle fois réuni plus de 10000 runner
les athlètes spécialiste de l'épreuve où
nos vies sont venus des quatre coins de
la france pour courir dans les jardins
du château de versailles
c'est versailles c'est la course entre
château de versailles c'est super 15 km
des parcours différents et il fait beau
et c'est top ca
ma troisième course à versailles j'ai
fait les brins sais c'est ma deuxième
royal et puis je cours régulièrement je
suis pas mal de courses donc faire ça il
sait pas ce que c'est beau mais c'est
parce que c'est l'occasion de faire une
course et il y en a pas beaucoup des 15
km pour cette sixième édition les
organisateurs avaient concocté un
parcours plus technique que les
dernières années objectif répondre aux
exigences des coureurs chevronnés
on passe du pavé au sentier à l'herbe
donc c'est un petit peu technique certes
des difficultés qui n'ont pas empêché
hamid belhaj de s'imposer le runner a
bouclé sa course royal en 49 minutes et
6 secondes
les devance de 35 secondes nicolas
dalmasso c'est le nouveau record de
l'épreuve l'air encore sans être méchant
créé pour être battus mais là il ya des
jours avec et des jours sans aujourd'hui
c'était avec et voilà le record de
l'épreuve est tombé mais voilà c'est ce
que le sportif tentera de défendre son
record l'année prochaine une septième
édition est déjà programmée pour juin
et on termine ce journal avec de la
musique la fête de la musique
hier soir avec de nombreuses
manifestations comme sur ces images
saint germain en laye et à bois d'arcy
mais il ya encore d'autres animations
ce week-end notamment comme le festival
de musique aux clayes sous bois
les sybelles et donc sarrois lieu au
parc de diane ce week-end à guyancourt
samedi les quartiers seront en fête avec
de la musique les animations dans les
rues et un concert à 18 heures à la
salle la batterie et enfin le concert
des enfants de demos de plaisir trappe
et de là derrière qui se déroulera
samedi soir à la philharmonique de paris
à côté de la cité de la musique
voilà c'est la fin de ce cette fuite le
journal merci nous avoir suivis tous nos
reportages sont à retrouver sur tv fil
78 points com ou sur l'application tv
fil 78 bonne soirée
[Musique]